ja so ist es geht nämlich gleich um die
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
die heute abgeben wird zum sondergipfel
des europäischen rates ende mai und da
geht es natürlich um die folgen des
ukraine krieges um energieeinsparung
aber auch um die verteidigungsfähigkeit
und deswegen habe ich mir zwei kundige
abgeordnete eingeladen einmal begrüßt
ganz herzlich michael roth den
vorsitzenden des auswärtigen ausschusses
und jürgen hardt den außenpolitische
sprecher der cdu/csu herr roth wir
müssen wir ganz aktuell darauf gucken
verteidigung habe ich gerade
angesprochen da geht es jetzt um die
nato beitritts wunsch von schweden und
finnland gestern war der außenminister
der türkei in amerika man hat verhandelt
sich offensichtlich noch nicht geeinigt
wir sehen auch hier wieder wie schwierig
das ist wenn das einstimmigkeitsprinzip
gilt was machen die türken da denn
nichts wäre ja wichtiger gegenüber dem
russischen despoten als dass man
gemeinsam auftritt und er verhindert
jetzt zunächst in weitere warum
politik in zeiten des krieges darf nicht
zu einem basar vorkommen und ich hoffe
dass am ende von der nato ein
geschlossenes signal ausgeht solidarität
und rationalität denn es liegt im
interesse aller nato staaten dass zwei
stabile demokratien mit starken armee zu
uns stoßen nicht nur weil sie selbst
angst vor der schreckensherrschaft
putins haben sondern weil sie auch jetzt
bereit sind intim nato mitzuarbeiten wir
in deutschland können vermutlich kaum
nachempfinden was das für eine
schwerwiegende auch dramatische
entscheidungen für finnland und für
schweden war finden hat eine fast 1400
kilometer grenze zu russland es gab dort
eine lange
zurückhaltung einer einem militärbündnis
beizutreten und jetzt hat putin abermals
verloren denn
jetzt tritt die nato an die direkte
grenze zu russland und das ist eine
weitere krachende niederlage für ihn er
hat aber die frage auf hatten sie noch
mal warum machen dass die türken ich
vermute dass da ganz handfeste türkische
interessen dahinter stehen ich glaube
aber dass die auch aus raum wahr sind
und ich bin mir sicher dass der
nato-gipfel im sommer beschließen wird
die finnen und die schäden in die nato
aufzunehmen ich plädiere dafür dass dann
der deutsche bundestag deshalb wird es
glaube ich ein ich dann auch möglichst
rasch das ratifikation gesetz macht also
die deutsche zustimmung zu dieser
entscheidung abgibt so dass die finden
und die schweden auch rasch unter den
schutzschirm des artikel 5 der nato
kommt und für uns als europäische union
als mitglieder der eu ist es ja sowieso
eine entlastung und zusätzliche stärkung
denn wir haben ja auch in dem vertrag
eine beistandsverpflichtung gegenüber
unseren mitgliedern finnland und
schweden nachdachte modelvertrag selbst
und wenn das durch die nato schutzschirm
in anführungsstrichen ergänzt wird ist
das eine stärkung deswegen ist das
innerhalb der europäischen union
eigentlich völlig unumstritten dass das
passiert der bundeskanzler hat in seiner
regierungserklärung am 27 februar hier
eine wegweisende rede gehalten im
deutschen haus heute im deutschen
bundestag heute erneute
regierungserklärung und die zentrale
ankündigung von damals nämlich das 100
milliarden sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr das steckt fest warum
das ist ein ganz weitreichender
beschluss der ja nicht nur auswirkungen
hat auch deutschland selbst sondern auch
auf unsere bündnispartner wir setzen
damit ein signal wir werden unserer
verantwortung für landesverteidigung
aber auch für die verteidigung unseres
bündnisses gerecht und wir ermutigen und
ermuntern damit natürlich auch andere
diesem beispiel zu folgen aber es geht
um 100 milliarden euro wir brauchen
dabei auch die zustimmung von cdu csu
das halte ich auch für wichtig nicht nur
weil wir zwei drittel mehrheit für eine
grundgesetzänderung brauchen sondern
weil auch gegenüber unserer eigenen
bevölkerung deutlich gemacht werden
sollte dass es hier nicht um aufrüstung
und militarisierung geht sondern dass
wir die bundeswehr endlich in eine lage
versetzen die sie braucht um in einer
zeit des krieges wehrhaft zu sein und da
haben wir noch ein paar gespräche zu
führen aber ich finde wichtig dass wir
uns einigen ob das nun eine woche später
oder eine woche früher ist das ist für
mich erst mal zweitrangig aber ich hab
die union und natürlich auch die
koalition so verstanden dass wir alle
hinter diesen großen historischen
projekt stehen er hat erst wurde mit der
union gar nicht gesprochen hat friedrich
merz gesagt es gab jetzt fruchtbare
gespräche die union ist schon lange von
der forderung wird das zwei prozent ziel
ins grundgesetz zu schreiben soll
begleitgesetz geben da blockieren so ein
bisschen wie die sozialdemokraten aber
bei den 100 milliarden rein für die
bundeswehr blockieren er die grünen wie
ist der sachstand im moment wir als cdu
csu opposition plädieren dafür dass das
was der kanzler am 27 februar gesagt hat
wort für wort umgesetzt wird er hat
gesagt 100 milliarden für verteidigung
im rahmen eines sondervermögens und zwei
prozent für die bundeswehr gemessen am
bruttoinlandsprodukt ab jetzt und wir
sagen das sind in zwei seiten ein und
derselben medaille wenn wir 100
milliarden die bundeswehr investiert
aber nicht gleichzeitig dafür sorgen
dass sie dieses gerät auch einführen
betreiben warten nutzen kann weil das
geld fehlt für personal oder für
material für ersatzteile dann würde das
ins leere laufen deswegen sind legen wir
großen wert darauf dass diese beiden
teile dieser aussage nämlich die 100
milliarden aber eben auch die 2 prozent
klar verbindlich im deutschen bundestag
beschlossen werden und das ist auch ein
punkt an dem wir im augenblick noch
regen aber ich glaube man kann es nicht
voneinander trennt man muss es im
zusammenhang sehen denn sonst würde das
gerät angeschafft werden und es würde
dann möglicherweise nicht dauerhaft in
der bundeswehr sinnvoll genutzt werden
also fingerhakeln wie ich die
abgeordneten kenne wird es irgendwann
eine lösung geben wohl nicht mehr im mai
herr roth gucken wir weiter der
bundestag hat ja auch beschlossen
schwere waffen zu liefern an die ukraine
dann hat der bundeskanzler kurz danach
gesagt also mit den sieben
panzerhaubitzen und mit denen geppert
panzern die ja beide sind ja noch lange
nicht drüber in der ukraine angekommen
da reicht es jetzt erst mal mehr können
wir nicht liefern jetzt ist heute zu
lesen dass im rahmen des ring tausches
leopard-2-panzer 15 stück an die türkei
geliefert wird die dann wiederum waffen
in die ukraine liefern wie ist der
sachstand werden wir noch weiteres
schweres gerät liefern oder nur im
rahmen dieses ringtausch also erstmal
bin ich sehr froh dass wir im bundestag
eine breite mehrheit gefunden haben um
unsere solidarität gegenüber der ukraine
zu bekunden humanitär politisch
finanziell aber eben auch militärisch
die ukraine braucht das was die
verteidigungsfähigkeit und da stehen
vermutlich noch lange schwere wochen und
monate vor ihr und dabei braucht sie
auch die unterstützung deutschlands ich
bin froh dass es jetzt endlich vorangeht
der ringtausch ist ja eine sehr
pragmatische und kurzfristige lösung um
die ukraine auch schnell in die lage
versetzt zu versetzen das gerät zu
bekommen was sie dringend braucht ich
bin tschechien sehr dankbar dass wir
jetzt diesen ringtausch ermöglichen
können moderne technologie aus
deutschland und technologie aus
sowjetischer produktion direkt in die
ukraine beim gepard ist es ein bisschen
schwieriger das ist ein industrieprojekt
wir müssen jetzt dafür sorge tragen dass
die ausbildung der ukrainischen
soldatinnen und soldaten rasch
gewährleistet wird und es wir brauchen
eine höhere stückzahl an munition und da
befindet sich die bundesregierung
momentan in einem intensiven gespräch
mit anderen partnern die über diese
munition noch verfügen mit das dilemma
mit der schweiz die ja nicht liefern
will kennen wir inzwischen das ist
traurig aber vielleicht gibt es auch
dort noch eine umkehr weil wenn man die
ukraine in diesen tagen nicht
unterstützt dann leistet man
unterstützung für russland und das
wollen sicherlich auch unsere schweizer
freundinnen und freunde nicht wobei es
gibt ja von dieser rüstungsfirma die
munition herstellt nicht nur ein werk in
der schweiz sondern in italien und
verteidigungsexperten sagen bevor der
gepard ausgebildet ist und repariert das
haben längst genug munition
also noch einmal ich finde es wichtig
dass wir mit dem gepard ein attraktives
angebot leisten damit die wehrhaftigkeit
der ukraine gesteigert werden kann und
wichtig es genügend munition und die
ausbildung muss gewährleistet werden und
da müssen wir jetzt alle unserer
verantwortung gerecht werden der
bundestagsbeschluss setzt dafür die
voraussetzung das ist glaube ich auch
wichtig gegenüber unserer eigenen
bevölkerung die sich ja sorgen macht
aber diese breite politische mehrheit in
deutschland
gewährleistet dass wir keine
unabsehbaren risiken eingehen aber wir
müssen uns auch an die seite der ukraine
stellen auch militärisch und wir müssen
ein klares stopp schild gegenüber dem
russischen accra aufstellen er hat die
verteilungs ministerin der bundeskanzler
sagen also mehr schweres gerät können
wir auch gar nicht liefern ich glaube
der kanzlerin zumindest hat es gerade
auch noch mal in einem interview der
deutschen welle gesagt sonst ist die
bundeswehr gar nicht
verteidigungsfähigkeit der
kanzleramtsminister hat noch hinzu
gesetz eigentlich sind wir ohne das
bündnis ähnlich
verteidigungsfähigkeit nicht aber der
bundestag beschlossenen schwere waffen
zu liefern
wir haben das gemeinsam beschlossen die
entscheidung gibt ist ja in die
diskussion über diesen antrag nein
geraten ich habe den eindruck dass
gebhard nicht ganz oben auf der
wunschliste der ukrainer stand weil es
eben ein relativ komplexes waffensystem
ist wo man lange ausbilden muss wir
hätten früher beginnen müssen mit der
ausbildung ukrainischen soldaten etwa an
den panzerhaubitzen wenn wir die
situation in der ukraine sehen dass
insbesondere verhindert werden muss dass
die russischen truppen städte besetzen
um dort entsprechende massaker
anzurichten das in panzerhaubitzen eine
gute abwehr war von wenn sie wenn wir
vor acht wochen oder vor zehn wochen mit
der ausbildung begonnen hätten dann
wären die franzosen und die soldaten
jetzt schon in der ukraine diese
verzögerung haben wir beklagt und die
haben auch jetzt den eindruck dass die
anträge von rüstungsunternehmen auf
export etwa von marder schützenpanzern
nicht mit der geschwindigkeit dem
kanzleramt bearbeitet werden wie wir uns
das wünschen das werden wir weiter aktiv
verfolgen als oppositionsfraktion wir
werden vielleicht nicht immer dass auf
der großen bühne machen aber es muss
mehr speed eingelegt werden das was der
bundestag beschlossen hat muss die
regierung auch machen sonst braucht der
bundestag eine andere regierung aber rot
noch mal zu der frage wir können nicht
mehr waffen abgeben die dialektik
verstehe ich nicht ganz wir geben jetzt
leopard-2-panzer übrigens von der
industrie die werden auch repariert und
dann hingestellt für die tschechen und
was aber noch zu lesen ist ist dass wir
verhandeln dass die tschechen 50 solcher
panzer uns abkaufen können ich habe ja
immer gedacht wir können keine waffen
abgeben also das versteht kein mensch
das kann man sehr gut verstehen wenn man
es gut genug erklärt und das versuche
ich jetzt einfach mal wir haben
einerseits die sehr begrenzten bestände
der bundeswehr selbst und da hat die
bundesregierung deutlich gemacht wir
können kaum noch etwas liefern aus
eigenen vorhandenen beständen weil wir
ansonsten auch unseren verpflichtungen
in der nato nicht mehr gerecht zu werden
vermögen das zweite sind natürlich
lieferungen die über die industrie
laufen wie beispielsweise jetzt auch
beim gepard die müssen dann teilweise
noch gewartet werden die ausbildung muss
gesichert werden aber selbstverständlich
kann man über den pool der industrie
noch weiteres zur verfügung stellen und
da rate ich sehr zu einer ganz
pragmatischen lösung die ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer wissen selbst am besten was
sie brauchen und dann müssen wir im team
nato im team eu rasch klären welches
land welche industrie kann am
schnellsten und am besten und am
sichersten das liefern was die ukraine
braucht also es geht nur in einer engen
zusammenarbeit mit den staaten
tschechien aber angesprochen das scheint
zu funktionieren die bekommen dann von
uns ersatz weil sie schneller liefern
können dann brauchen wir eine
zusammenarbeit mit der industrie und wir
brauchen natürlich auch eine enge
zusammenarbeit mit der ukraine denn die
muss schließlich sagen was sie braucht
residenz gehört gesagt er richtet sich
auf einen längeren krieg ein dann ist ja
die frage dieses ringtausch es auf dauer
für die bundesregierung vielleicht gar
nicht mehr machbar weil immer mehr
waffen gebraucht werden aber sei es drum
herr borel dass der außenbeauftragte der
eu hat jetzt gerade eine wunschliste
aufgestellt was die eu an waffensystemen
braucht herr hat wenn man das ist ja
auch ein europäischer gipfel wenn man
auf die europäer cook muss man nicht
konstatieren dass sie ohne die
amerikaner eigentlich gar nicht
handlungsfähig sind und wenn man eine
europäische gemeinsam haben je weiter
voranbringen will muss man da nicht
anfangen mit diesen vielen geld die 100
milliarden und anderes geld in anderen
eu-ländern
waffensysteme anzuschaffen aber nicht
jedes land die gleichen sondern daneben
diese liste von hamburger abarbeiten ich
glaube dass das ein großes problem ist
innerhalb der europäischen nato partner
dass wir zu viele gleichartige
waffensysteme parallel im einsatz haben
was enorm die kosten erhöht hat und auch
die ausbildung ingrid schwierig macht
ich glaube dass wir bei der
neubeschaffung der bundeswehr enger mit
anderen eu mindestens europäischen nato
partner kooperieren sollten und auch
bestimmte dinge gemeinsam machen sollten
zum beispiel die wartung zum beispiel
die ausbildung an den waffensystemen das
spart viel geld und es gibt ja
deutsch-französische insbesondere
deutsch-französische bemühungen um
gemeinsamer waffen sowohl für das
luftverteidigung als auch für das land
system also panzer zukunft panzer der
zukunft das steckt leider nach wie vor
in schwierigkeiten und ich glaube dass
der weckruf aus kiew dass wir jetzt gas
geben müssen in der eu hoffentlich auch
dafür sorgt dass diese konsolidierung
gemeinsame rüstungsanstrengungen
voranschreitet ich glaube auch dass wir
als europäer immer auch waffensysteme
der nato haben sollten die
amerikanischen system gleichwertigkeit
ebenbürtig so denn wie wir von einer art
waffe nur ein system mit der nato
einführen dann ist natürlich der das
herstellt in einem enormen vorteil der
konkurrenz belebt auch da das geschäft
und die qualität wird besser wenn wir
europäische und amerikanische top
systeme zur verfügung hält der
amerikanische präsident hat gesagt es
ist durchaus möglich dass die ukraine
diesen krieg gewinnt das ist eigentlich
auch das ziel des westens der
bundeskanzler das so deutlich nicht
gesagt er hat ja auch schon mit dem
russischen präsidenten telefoniert hat
ja noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass ein
schneller waffenstillstand kommen muss
das keine nazis in kiew sitzen und dass
die ukraine verantwortlich ist für die
lebensmittel situation auf der welt aber
er hat zum beispiel auch nicht vom
rückzug der russischen truppen aus dem
ukrainisch nie gesprochen wird er das
heute hier tun wird er klar definieren
wie dieser krieg zu ende gehen kann und
dass die russen sich zurückziehen müssen
wir haben im team westen gemeinsam mit
der ukraine ein strategisches ziel dass
die ukraine als freis souveränes
demokratisches land diesen krieg
übersteht das ist unser ziel und am ende
muss die ukraine selbst entscheiden
welchen kompromiss sie bereit ist
einzugehen was mich an der debatte
wahnsinnig stört ist dass wir niemals an
in richtung kreml fragen was müsst ihr
denn eigentlich an leistungen erbringen
damit wir diesen krieg diplomatisch
friedlich beenden können und
selbstverständlich muss ein
waffenstillstand geknüpft sein an einen
rückzug der russischen truppen das hat
der bundeskanzler auch immer wieder
gesagt und ob er es heute nochmal sagt
weiß ich nicht aber es wäre sicherlich
nochmal ein klares signal um auf
missverständnissen vorzubeugen er hat
jetzt haben wir gar nicht über die
energieproblematik gesprochen aber das
wird vielleicht jetzt gleich in der
debatte der fall sein der bundeskanzler
aber zunächst eine regierungserklärung
abgeben dann werden die abgeordneten 90
minuten diskutieren sie können live
dabei sein
sie beraten